in early 1963 after the success of
characters such as spider-man Iron Man
Hulk and for Stanley envisioned a group
of superheroes who derived their powers
not from godhood for technological
advancements or scientific experiments
gone wrong but from genetic mutation
this gamble would ultimately pay off and
forever change the marvel comics
landscape what's going on guys
this is rob and today we're going to be
talking about the x-men
so when the xmin refers to introduce the
1963 marvel was looking for something
new they were looking for something
different and they were wanting to take
things in a different direction because
prior to the x-men
there was a really antiquated way of
doing comic books it is to say that it
was very racially antiquated pretty much
all the incantations of comic book
superheroes main mainstream very popular
superheroes including the first
incantation of the x-men were all white
and society was in a position where it
was beginning to transition it was
beginning to change I mean in 1963 that
was eight years after Claudette Colvin
who was the first black woman to be
arrested for refusing to give up her
seat to a white man on a city bus and so
you began to see the civil rights
movement really kind of take form about
1963 the civil rights movement was kind
of on its way out at the same time we
were in the middle of the Cold War and
even then the Cold War was beginning to
die down in a go away of course it
wouldn't end for another 20 years but
the Cold War was still somewhat
beginning to come to a close there were
a lot of social impacts on comic books
in addition to this you already had
characters in the Marvel Universe who
were extremely popular and who are
already who had already kind of been set
in stone in the sense of their character
powers their character developments and
they already had major fan followings I
mean Iron Man Thor spider-man the
Fantastic Four
these were well established superheroes
and when the x-men were introduced they
were one very boring in terms of their
powers and two they were new because
they introduced something that had never
been seen before they introduced the
element of mutant powers now with
regards to the idea of previous
superheroes people were able to identify
with this because despite the fact that
they achieved various means to gain
superpowers or to gain some sort of
enhancements at the end of the day there
were still just regular people but once
the idea of the x-men began to catch on
the people really began to get on board
especially in 1975 when the series was
rebooted because of the fact that the
x-men had really lagged behind virtually
everybody else in terms of sales Marvel
came to the decision they were going to
reboot the series and if the reboot
failed they were never going to reboot
it again they were just going to leave
it dead when 1975 came around in issue
number one of giant-size x-men we saw a
complete new introduction of an
line up the only exception was the
return of cyclops as the team's leader
but because of the fact that society had
been far more progressive than it was
before because of the fact that we had
seen the introduction of major black
superheroes like black panther in 1966
society was looking for a more
progressive team of superheroes not in
the sense of their political viewpoints
or their social viewpoints but in terms
of the racial lineup of the team and so
Marvel introduces kind of multicultural
group of people who hailed from
different geographical locations at the
same time there were also adults and so
they were more mature in terms of their
viewpoints of the world because the
original x-men team were composed of
super um sort of teenagers now with this
new incantation of the x-men they hit
the ground running I mean they took off
full force and some of the greatest
storylines that we had ever seen in
Marvel Comics originated with this group
of course we saw storylines revolving
around multiple man around the
introduction of mystique more McTaggart
a genetic researcher from your island
the Canadian team Alpha Flight the
starjammers who of course introduced the
idea that Scott Scott Summers parents or
that his father was not dead and that
his father was in fact alive and that he
had a third Sommers brother the
introduction of the Proteus saga the in
a mutant with the ability to work
reality albeit on a much smaller scale
than someone like Franklin Richards or
Mad Jim Jasper's in addition what we
also saw was the Marvel Comics take a
much darker turn at the hands of the
x-men specifically with regards to the
Dark Phoenix saga and the Days of Future
past with the darks Phoenix saga I
really feel like this was the storyline
that set everything in motion with
regards to Marvel Comics becoming much
darker because the Phoenix was this
elemental force in the universe that was
virtually incorruptible and then the
Phoenix comes under the manipulation of
mastermind and is subtly now corrupted
with emotions and with the drive to
experience more of these emotions and I
think this is what really kind of
changed things because now you know
we're previous incantations of Marvel
Comics inventing all the superhero doing
the right thing fighting the good fight
you know and always knowing what the
right thing is
now we saw this world where the line
between right and wrong was blurry at
best and sometimes it didn't even exist
sometimes it wasn't even there because
there was no right decision and there
was no wrong decision it was just a
decision that needed to be made and
somebody somewhere was going to die and
there was nothing you could do about it
now with regards to the x-men team as a
whole a lot of people look at a team
like The Avengers and they say well the
Avengers are earth mightiest heroes and
they're you know the the greatest team
in all honesty I would say that the
x-men were probably the premier team in
the Marvel Comics and when people think
about Marvel I can almost guarantee one
of the first teams they think of is the
x-men and the reason for this is because
some of the most popular and prominent
characters in Marvel Comics had either
been villains allies or part of the
x-men you know they kind of seemed to be
this interchanging thing where a
character rises up in popularity and by
virtue of coming into contact with the
x-men raises the popularity of the x-men
as well at the same time the x-men
benefit characters I mean the x-men had
some very interesting plots even just
outside of the realm of these big
storylines
and more in the realm of character
development I mean for example the love
triangle between Jean Grey and Scott
Summers and Wolverine is extremely
popular among Marvel comic fans that a
lot of people know what the storyline is
it influences a lot of the actions that
Wolverine could have taken but didn't
take we also saw the introduction of
things like the scrolls a shape-shifting
invading alien race one of which took on
the form of Wolverine we saw storylines
like the 12 which was apocalypses
attempt to gain godhood by virtue of
combining the powers of 12 particular
mutants into the living monolith and
then channeling those powers into
himself to grant him virtual omnipotence
the x-men had some of the greatest
storylines of all time had some of the
best character development of all time
and introduced to us some of our
favorite characters in the history of
Marvel and so the x-men's impact on
Marvel Comics has been long and standing
and there's a reason why the team is so
popular because they've done so much
they've introduced so much to say
nothing of the introduction of a mutant
gene that grants people superpowers I
mean this moved away from the idea of
previous superheroes developing
technological advancements or
enhancements or superpowers based on
some sort of
factor I mean prior to the x-men it was
all external the Fantastic Four were hit
with cosmic radiation Tony Stark used
his technological knowledge to create
the Iron Man suit and the other
incantations of technological armor the
The Incredible Hulk was the result of a
botched gamma-ray experiment and
spider-man was bitten by radioactive
spider the x-men it was just some gene
that existed in their body that may or
may not manifest itself during their
adolescence of a particular person or
during adulthood or even prior to their
adolescence and they were kind of on
this this quest to somehow gain control
of their powers and there was a road
they had to take they can either become
bad guys or they could become good guys
and the storylines would circle around
that so with that being said I'm going
to go ahead and ring this video to an
end I hope you guys enjoyed it if you
did let me know and I will catch you
guys later peace